how do you stay driven I'm gonna ask you
a question how don't you stay driven
well let me get this right you won the
lotto of the universe which is you are a
human being on earth and you're not
driven and you're not fired up and
you're not going for it and you're
willing to sit like a lump and just wait
till you die you suck
[Music]
we're running the gamut of somebody
who's literally in the Hall of Fame to
somebody who literally didn't make it
into a first season but it's all the
same thesis as to why I was intrigued by
our call how we got to this second
meeting which is listen there's gonna be
a percent there's a percentage of with
no question I'm gonna be able to walk
into Mama's house across the country and
win because the ones that have the best
emotional intelligence are gonna realize
I'm gonna do a better job for their son
than the majority as all this digital
stuff works as you know I have five
fourteen year-old girls making more
money on musically with content I'm
doing then [ __ ] first-round picks in
the NFL and NBA Draft making [ __ ]
endorsements in a year it's crazy
so I'll win that I want to surround the
agency with that and so what the agency
wants to do is be incredible sports
agents like really know how to do
contracts and all that stuff but become
the greatest machine ever in the
building of personal brand and in
endorsements but really and I think
you're gonna like this based on it
sounds like your upbringing I really
want people to feel like they're like in
eight years ten years I want the
reputation of inner sports to be like
you go there because they teach your son
how to become a man for real
real pleasure yeah you got a shoe elf
yes
name's Tyler Schmidt I have been working
here at Vayner November will be three
years November 11th and I first started
as a community manager here then got to
know Gary and AJ through playing morning
basketball I'm I was taking my used to
take a 5:15 train in from Jersey just to
get to know those guys and then one day
AJ was looking for an assistant Gary's
younger brother and I said whatever the
hell I can do to make that happen I
would love to and so I met with AJ a
couple times one thing led to another
and I moved into that role was with the
AJ up until he stepped away and when he
stepped away I was kind of thinking
about what else to do and Gary kind of
brought it up to me about the potential
of doing it
and after doing it for two years it was
I you know I made the decision overnight
to end up working with him because it
was a no-brainer but it's definitely an
interesting role with AJ it was very
operational it was very you know about
the internal vaynermedia operations and
then Gary's just a whole different piece
in the sense of you know he's the CEO of
vaynermedia but at the same time that's
like one of a million different things
that he's doing and so it was definitely
a learning curve in terms of speed in
terms of work ethic in terms of hours
that I've put in and at first he was
super tough for me actually because I
was trying to operate in my old ways of
the amount of time that I was working
the focus that I was putting in at work
and I wasn't doing a good job which in
turn was tough because I was like oh you
know I I wasn't adjusting to what the
role needed and then just was thinking
that the role was hard and and like oh
this stuff stuff out of that but once I
changed my mindset in terms of like
this is super doable you just need to
attack it and start working more so now
I've been putting in the hours and the
more I've been working the more I've
come to love it I would tell you and the
way most people digest environment is
very different than the way I do for
example if you think of it as just a
human base thing the amount of people
that come out of homes that aren't
pretty and don't have good skylines
and come out and our straight winners I
grew up in a townhouse that environment
it was you know like it's not about
having a foosball table the environment
is only the people it's not the tables
and the chairs and the views and the
location people always like look Gary
we've updated our office and we're like
you now we're open I'm like you're the
furthest thing from us ever when you are
forced to do the right thing you're
doing the wrong place
either you just are or you aren't this
is binary hardwiring Mike might eat
those who I am is adversity is underdog
I won the wine world I won the wine
business world
how did I do what did I do with that I
left it and came into an industry where
I was nothing and everybody made fun of
me I'm Twitter boy have a lot of Twitter
followers I'm gonna start an agency and
now I'm [ __ ] sticking it to their
faces right and I'm and now I'm almost
done then another five or seven years
I'll build the undisputed great agency
of this generation and you know I'm
gonna handle that not by cashing in and
[ __ ] laying on a beach I'm gonna I'm
gonna do what I always do which is walk
directly away from it and start a new
challenge where I'm the underdog wait he
can't do that that has nothing to do
don't forget what I did I went from the
wine retail business to the advertising
agent that had no connection
and so you know I don't know I'm gonna
go win a [ __ ] Golden Globe or
something but mostly seeking the dirt
when they should be looking for the
clouds I would say 80% of the time
I sure can 80% of time people are asking
me for a tactic that's gonna allow them
to win when they don't realize that it's
the strategy that's got them stuck to
begin with their North Star what they're
trying to achieve and and so almost all
the time it's a dirt question Gary how
exactly do I use Facebook to make a
trillion dollars have have you thought
about like not trying to make a trillion
dollars in five seconds have you thought
about understanding communication before
you worry about what it means in the
Facebook environment so almost every
question that's asked to me as a dirt
question and almost everything I do is
predicated on a clouds strategy
[Music]
how do you stay driven I'm gonna ask you
a question how don't you stay together
let me get this right you won the lotto
of the universe which is you are a human
being on earth you I'm just gonna say
this I mean I don't think people think
about this you won the lotto you in the
universe you're not some weird specimen
in Mars that does nothing you're not you
know a bird you know you know you're not
a sunflower like you're a human being on
earth you won the ultimate ultimate
lottery and you're not driven and you're
not fired up and you're not going for it
and you're willing to sit like a lump
and just wait till you die you suck
right like I don't know you suck like I
how do I stay driven because I couldn't
even comprehend the alternative and by
the way by the way let me let me clarify
one thing if you're happy with your life
and you don't complain play pokemon go
fifteen hours a day right it's too many
people complain that they're not winning
and they're not auditing their actions
and realizing that they're spending too
much of their allocation of time on
leisure and escapism and that's fine
but work is the variable of success it's
work at some level I'm just trying to be
realistic how about just having a
conversation of that you don't know a
single person on earth that's successful
that didn't put in work nobody watching
this right now nobody watching this
right now knows a single person that
became successful without the work we
have different levels of talent all that
but work required by friends work
required another good day super
productive banging out operations at
scale
client stuff just really really saw
their going to a little bit of a vent
here at Hudson Yards now
another kind of respect meeting tonight
just grinding along tomorrow big day
Jets football season on the line she's
not gonna hide five seconds of this
world anyway I hope everybody's doing
well talk to you soon